feed us now live chair you can commence
with the meeting
okay right well
now we've got going uh it's welcome to
the meeting of the standards committee
uh this is a public meeting being
streamed
live to youtube and via the council's
website
the meeting is also being recorded for
the purposes of the millions
i've been advised that the live stream
is now
up and running if for any reason the
public can no longer hear
or see the meeting over the live stream
uh let us know and we will adjourn
until the connection has been
reestablished
can i ask the governance officer to
explain the procedure for this meeting
thank you chair nichola carver
governance manager uh this is just a
reminder for the members who are present
this meeting to keep your cameras on for
the duration of the meeting
for voting today we're going to take a
different approach
we have all the polls for all the boats
loaded up and we can issue them at any
time
but should the chair require for us to
do a vote by hands if you can clearly
raise your hand
close to your face then we should be
able to see it on screen
um a reminder for our co-opted
member um patricia coleman that you're
not permitted to vote so when i do issue
the when i do issue the poll votes which
come up on your screen you don't need to
press anything
yes okay thanks um if all members can
just be aware of your surroundings for
this meeting
um and just a reminder that we are live
streamed and it will be recorded i'm
just gonna
issue the recording now so you'll hear a
little announcement
this meeting is being recorded
okay thank you chair so in the meeting
room today you
have um yourself counselor william
armitage is the chair
councillor kathy rouse counselor jackie
ridgway
councillor richard welton council david
hancock
councillor diana ruff councillor heather
liggett
and councillor pat kerry we also have
our co-opted member patricia coleman
and the uh the monitoring officer sarah
sternberg
and myself the governance manager and
amy brian
from the governance team thank you chair
thank you nicola uh
first of all i'd like to welcome richard
welton
to our uh committee it's good to see you
here richard
if we give everybody away we know who
you are do your way thank you william
welcome you myself i'll take it i'm not
so welcome william
no one said that
hey it's a political remember that
oh yes of course you've changed yes
i mean you're coming to this one too
yeah
yes i i forgot that you're
compatriot has come to
come to planning now so yes and we would
like to welcome david hancock
so give us away baby
have we got the cat there as well today
uh i'm sure she'll appear at some point
right okay then right
uh if we go first of all to i to one of
the agenda
and that's apologists for
[Music]
parish councillor derek skinner has also
sent apologies
right thank you for that right
item two declarations of interest
members are requested to declare
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interest
and or other interests not already
on their register of interest uh
in any item on the agenda uh if they
have these interests
they will withdraw from the meeting at
the appropriate time
uh just one thing uh i can't see
anything on the i can see
a few members on the lives on my screen
but uh if you wish to speak uh
if you could go through uh the
governor's manager
nicola i think she can see everybody
can't you nicola
yes chair i can so i'm happy to keep an
eye out and let you know when members
wish to speak
okay right thank you uh item
three uh is the minute to the last
meeting
uh it's to approve as correct
uh for myself the sign the minutes of
the standards committee heard
on the 1st of july 2020.
so any questions for these
[Applause]
so
okay
has everybody had the opportunity to
vote
i'll just share the results on your
screen now that six votes four with one
abstention
that's carried chair thank you
right uh
we go to item four
which is the standards committee
annual draft report and
i will ask the governance officer
to go through it um
thank you chair this is the committee's
annual report that's submitted to
council
um this was due to come to you at your
first or your first meeting of the
municipal year and apologies to all that
was not completed in time
so although this has come a little late
to you it's nonetheless a comprehensive
review of your activity
over the 1920 civic year
um the report covers the work you've
undertaken in regard to complaints
and it includes that the appendices
reports the independent persons
and the outcomes of the local government
ombudsman referrals
at 7.1 it lists the areas of the
constitution
that you've covered recommended to
council for adoption
and subsequent ranges subsequent changes
and now in your 2020 version of the
constitution
which all members of the standards
committee should have a copy of
the committee over the past year
discussed at length the code of conduct
and specifically the flinchier standard
if you'll remember
which seemed to document which might
underpin and reinforce some of the
messages within our local code of
conduct
however since that point uh the
parliamentary committee the standards in
public life have
since consulted on a new model and it's
hoped that the new code
um which will be brought forward for
consideration by yourself at a future
standards committee
will encompass many of the messages
within that lynchia standard
um and if it doesn't it'll be an ideal
opportunity at that point
to add it to our own code thank you
chair
thank you for that nichola are there any
questions
all nice and quiet i can't see anybody
waving
okay right well uh we'll take a vote on
that
uh and we'll do it uh yes
it'll be quite well there the poll so
if you fought or against and then
sublimate
so with seven votes for chair that's
carried
have i just want to check that all
members are able to
access that um because i'm expecting in
eight votes
did everybody manage to click on on that
for voting
okay thank you chair thank you
right uh we come to item five
which is the gifts and hospitality
review
from 2019 uh
needs to receive a report advising the
committee of the entries
in the council's gift and hospitality
registered during
2019.
good that's uh that's me again chair
um this is another annual report
brought to the committee a little later
than planned due to the coveted
situation
um you'll see if you have a look at the
appendices that there are four
registrations that were made
during 2019 and they're on page 21.
the current protocol requests for gifts
favors or hospitality above the value of
25 to be registered
um for members interest um the
governance team
are currently developing online
registers to digitalize this
and we're going to hopefully do that
through the mod.gov
system and maybe at a future meeting
we'll be able to give you a short
demonstration
on how that would work so the
recommendation in the report is is to
note the gifts and hospitality register
okay well uh
shall we go to the vote on that i
thought well any questions first on this
no mems are indicating they wish to
speak chair
right okay
well uh we've got we'll go to the vote
then on this
so if you get the poll ready
nicola nikki oh sorry i realized i was
muted at that point
yeah um it's when i was trying to vote
just it said the poll
closed i apologize apologies there was a
little problem with it i'm just going to
relaunch it for you all i was trying to
explain that but i've left myself muted
i'm just going to relaunch it for you
all now
and that poll is now live for you
again i'm just checking that all members
are able to vote on this because i'm not
receiving in the amount of votes
expected there we are
chair with all votes for that would be
carried
okay thank you very much
right uh item six emerging
emergency allegations and that's to
receive a report
informing the committee of decisions
that have been made
under the delegated powers to act in
an emergency and asked sarah sternberg
uh tell us about this thank you chad
as locked down approached in march we
looked at what delegations would be
needed to keep council services
uh going uh particularly in the early
stages of lockdown
there was already an emergency
delegation for the head of paid service
in the constitution
and that that was used on a number of
occasions and those occasions are listed
at 1.2 of the report
mostly it was used to put in place other
emergency delegations
to key as i say to keep services going
to keep licensing going etc
the list is at pages 28 to 32
and 1.5 shows what these have been used
for
and i have to say they've been used on
relatively few occasions and largely in
relation to policies
constitutionally the use of the powers
must be reported back
and it is also very much good governance
to do so
so these are here for your review and
noting thank you
thank you sarah for that right uh
any questions
classic hancock is indicating
yes if you can unmute and ask a question
thank you chair um it's just a brief
question because
obviously a lot of these are to replace
cabinet decisions
um and notice that it was renewed after
legislation was introduced that allowed
for remote meetings so i'm wondering why
we didn't scale it down
at that point chair it was scaled down
in that it was reviewed for two months
and it was
renewed for two months rather than three
very much of the catch-all exercise yes
the virtual meetings were taking place
but just to ensure that nothing slipped
through the gaps
it was renewed again i'm about to start
talking to the leader about whether it
needs renewing at all
in the next period thank you
any of your questions
no further indications chair okay
well if you could uh go to the vote on
that please
remember as you'll see in front of you
now the
electronic poll
all members have had an opportunity to
do that
nikki councillor kerry's got his hand up
apologies chad councillor kerry's
indicating his wish to speak
okay
um i'm pressing i'm getting a circle
come round
and then i lose contact and they save me
out of the meeting and come back in
and i'm i'm missing this as a section
can i
be promoted can i vote with my hand
because i seem to be losing the voting
on the on the box that comes up
um so so i think as i advise i think we
i did
mention that we i think we were missing
a vote from a member chair what would
you like to do would you like me to
continue with the electronic poll
and do council carry separately or would
you like to just go to a show of hands
i think for ease of management we'll go
to a show hands
i haven't voted against you at all
hopefully now i voted
for each time
okay thank you for that part
right uh so are we taking the vote uh
again as last time or are we here
um chair would you like to um
conduct a vote as you would do in the
chamber as in for against
an abstaining i can count those votes
for you okay
so all those in favor please raise their
hand
chair that's all members in favor that's
eight
thank you for that right
uh we'll move now to item seven
uh the re reveal the constitution for
two uh and we come to uh
first of all seven a uh contract
procedure rules so have you all received
these
yes okay
well perhaps sarah could
go through
yes chairman this is just a regular
update of the council procedure rules
it is incorporated the fact that we've
left the european union
and reinforced the position of the
procurement in the process um i'll try
and answer any questions you have on
this
any specific amendments but just to say
that it's not
meant to be a fundamental change just an
update
thank you for that uh are there any
questions
thank you i've got um a few i've
kind of put a few scribbled notes so
bear with me um
4.2 the whole paragraph
has been deleted
um and i'm a bit concerned about that
i don't think that paragraph actually
adds anything it dates back from when we
have things like
compulsory competitive tendering and
there was an issue whether your internal
service had to
compete for it i think it's historic and
i think that's why it's been removed
right um 12.1
and i kind of get the logic behind this
um but i'm not sure if it's tightening
things up a little bit too much because
sometimes an external
offers that impartial eye that an
internal can't
yeah sorry yeah i wouldn't
read that as preventing getting in an
external consultant
right it's um yeah there are two
situations where you've worked
and right thank you and there was just
one of the which was a comment which i
was going to ask and i can't find where
i've marked it now but
there's there's one particular point i
was just going to ask if we could do it
differently in future
um there's one where we set an amount
and the crossings are so complicated if
you actually it's the same thing in
about three different times and it
actually looks like three different
figures
so could we actually just delete the
whole figure and put it in the fresh
so it becomes less less confusing when
you're going through it if that's all
right
yeah we can sort that out that's fine
here thank you
okay do we have any uh
any questions
no indications chair okay right
we come now to uh 7p
uh it's about the planning committee and
ward members
uh if i could just uh remind everybody
board members currently can vote and
remain as part of the planning
committee for applications within their
war
but as part of the annual constitutional
changes in may
2020 it was introduced that ward members
could no longer vote
on applications within their wars
but could speak for or against them
the change was suspended uh
pending a full review by standards
i understand that this uh was introduced
primarily
from a governor's perspective
given that the licensing committee
members cannot vote on
applications in their awards and as
there has been a history of
recent complaints all be not upheld
in this card due to covid
this has been introduced at the annual
full council meeting
pending a standard for review however
on further discussion with councillors
it is clear
that this blanket approach is still
strong
but there are many instances where ward
members
can vote on applications in their awards
without conflict and can add local
knowledge
therefore it is to propose to revoke the
constitutional
amendment and revert to the previous
policy
but with the guidance
and advisory note to planning committee
members
that they should not vote on
applications
in which they have a pre-developed
predetermined view
or a conflict of interest
any comments
i fully support the the change i think
whilst i understand the logic behind
this is that it's attempting to
um to protect the integrity of the
process i think it actually falls short
on on quite a few areas um 50
of our groups are made up by people who
are all from the same
ward so at that point we've totally
disrupted the political balance of the
of the um committee which we shouldn't
be doing on planning or licensing
we're also taking the issue that people
shouldn't but of course parish
boundaries and district boundaries
differ to award boundaries so you
potentially have someone who
is subject to that that electorate
making a decision at a district level
anyway
so again the logic that that is there is
is certainly flawed
so i fully support the withdrawal of
this um and
with the additional recommendations that
obviously members are aware of the
dangers of pre-determination
and obviously conflict of interest which
goes without saying
so i i support the the change that is
being proposed
and not the one that was put forward
councillor welton you wish to speak yes
thank you chad i'm not on planning
i do take a different view probably from
experiences elsewhere in the corporate
world
and i've also listened on a number of
occasions to presentations
about the problems with too many
decisions from planning
being reversed on appeal and how this
can affect the amount of money that the
council has
and big big bills coming in we also know
with the white paper that position is
probably going to get
worse as well to me it's a lot cleaner
and it's just very very clean that you
know if
you don't sit and you don't talk or vote
on a matter within your ward and i think
that is just
um it's just a cl it's just a cleaner um
logical way of dealing with it and
stopping you going through thank you
okay uh councillor liggett
i'm afraid i'm afraid i disagree with
richard and i agree with david
um you know i'm sorry but i think
local knowledge and how we were before
is a lot better way to go
thank you for that uh counsellor ralph
yeah and we agree with richard and
it worked exceptionally well yesterday
prime example
one of our board members she was on the
planning committee
stepped down she spoke had a substitute
we've all got substitutes
it's much cleaner it's much fairer it
takes a lot of pressure off of board
members
especially if it goes wrong and and i
fully support this
and it's one thing i think quite
strongly about
okay thank you uh councillor ridgeway
wishes to speak
um as being on the planning committee i
agree with
councillor liggett and councillor
hancock i do think
you know your ward better and hopefully
as counselors we
we should know that you know if we've
got that if we have got a predetermined
view on it then we shouldn't be opening
our mouths and voting so it's part of
what we should be doing anyway
you any further questions on this
it's all very emotive really
uh as far as i'm concerned
i think the electorate expects you to
speak on it
and and to vote on it and it's expected
of you
yes you can come in uh
if somebody puts it against you
but if you obey the rules and do it
properly
and don't give any signs of a
predetermination
uh or a conflict of interest then you
have nothing to worry about
but uh it is entirely up to yourselves
and i think on this
we should maybe ask
governance to make a comment on this
first
um sorry sarah did you want to take this
one
i was just going to say this is a just a
recommendation for good governance as
has been mentioned it happens in
relation to licensing cases
it does ensure differentiation between
somebody who has
got a personal interest or predetermined
the matter from the rest of the
committee
but as has been pointed out you're under
that obligation anyway
nikki do you want to add anything i was
just going to run through for members
the rationale behind
the change just so that you're aware um
before you make your decision
um so the rationale that we put forward
was that whilst obviously that we know
that members are fully aware of
predetermination matters removing
voting rights on local applications can
protect ward members
from pre-determination claims um that
could be from local residents or
developers
um also some elective representatives
may view that members appointed to the
planning committee have an advantage to
those not on planning committee to
influence decisions within their boards
so really the proposal is put forward
really to protect members from pressures
within their electorate and
electioneering
removing complications of voting against
all four applications
and the constituents view on this and it
allows members to fully represent
the views of their awards at each
planning committee
when it comes to remote meetings and
virtual meetings and
it's proved really easy for members to
um appoint substitutes
um even for specific applications that's
something that we could look into in
future so
i think there are ways that we can if
even if you didn't agree a change to the
constitution today
i think there are ways in which we can
support members further with this um
and we'll be happy to explore those and
suggest anything that might uh that
might support members in
in the consideration of plea
determination or matters in their wars
thank you for that well
uh we'll put it to the vote who's in
favor and who isn't
uh and see
what you think but be be careful how you
do it
think very carefully think how it will
affect
you personally uh and
if we could go to the poll
uh chair yeah i can issue a poll um if
counselor kerry is struggling to vote
um please let me know
so that's launched
to cancel the proposal
just for clarity is the proposal was put
to the meeting
to not accept this or is the proposal to
accept this before we actually
sorry it's not very clear no the reason
for that is i wasn't
sure which way he would go during the
meeting so
um so when i set the path in advance
apologies so
um uh chair you don't have um you have
members who who are in favor of it and
members
who are against it so you probably want
emotion on the table of of
going to the boat so you want a proposal
from the floor
yeah church and nicola just i'm
obviously
also confused as well is i know what i
want the outcome to be i want to vote
for
ward members not to be allowed to sit on
the planning committee so which way
am i voting for or against can someone
tell me so i can register my
which way i want to go chair would you
like to make a proposal to the meeting
uh uh i propose that we go back to the
old system
where ward members can vote
so if you don't want that chair then
you're voting against the proposal okay
yeah dr clarity just before i issued the
vote
so the recommendation put um puts the
meeting is to
rescind uh the change to the
constitution formally
um so that ward members may continue to
sit on planning committee and vote so
i'm just going to relaunch that poll
okay that's all members voting
and with six votes four um and
two against um that's motion
the motion that council armitage put his
is carried
so to clarify for members that would
mean that uh this this
issue would go no further we wouldn't be
putting it back into the constitution
okay so it goes to
uh the full council now does it as a
recommendation
um chair no that would not go too oh
sorry sarah go ahead
nikki i think it would go to council
because at the moment we have a position
where the council has agreed to include
it
in as a provision in the constitution so
they would need to make the decision to
take it out
thank you thank you so that would go as
a recommendation to council to remove
thank you right item eight uh
career of the uh complaints update
please
thank you chair at the moment we have
nine complaints
with one near enclosure the number of
complaints about parish councils are six
and the number about district
councillors is three
i just want to take this opportunity to
let you all know
that um vicky dawson who is my deputy
monitoring officer
has recently been successful in getting
the head of housing job at bowls over
council
so she has officially left the role but
he's
working in the meantime to help me a
little bit with some of this
but obviously that leaves a big gap and
it has already started to have
consequences in terms of how
quickly we can get these moving so i
just wanted to alert you to the fact
that we're not
being as quick with them as we would
like
thanks chair thank you for that
uh item nine the work
program all right william can i just ask
um sarah's question
sarah in your report there were five
outstanding
for 20 19 20 if they've been resolved
um can i get back to you because i've
actually got the figures for 2019 20 in
front of me i'll get back to you on that
one
okay thank you okay
right that's uh if you come now to uh
item nine and that's a work program uh
just to update or amend the work program
for the
current municipal year
so uh
nicola are you i think amy's taking this
one
yeah i think that's me so appreciate set
out for your next three meetings so if
there's anything you'd like to add or
change around then let us know and we
can
you can make those changes
okay you have no indications to speak on
this
yes yeah whereabouts is this sorry i
can't find it in my papers that's
all look at
the original pack page 49
page 49 yes okay
just bear with me sorry
okay
okay thank you okay
anything that uh people would like to
put anything else in fox
no indications chair okay
right well
item 10 urgent business uh is there any
urgent business
there's nothing from myself about
anybody else
again no indications chair okay
right uh the date of the next meeting
is the 9th of december
so uh bring your uh
christmas break with you
and uh uh like first of all to thank you
all very much for
coming today uh and i'd like to thank
the
officers for their help and guidance on
this
uh committee so if there's nothing else
oh and of course
just thank david hancock
i think check would it be appropriate
for us to thank vicky through sarah for
all the work she's done because she's
been brilliant over all the years
yes yeah i'd be delighted to relay that
thank you yeah
okay then well uh i declare the meeting
close and thank you all again
you